Півмісяця підготовки та безсонних ночей.
І ось до акції протесту готові.
Олександр хоче домогтися від парламенту і президента
ухвалення змін до виборчого законодавства,
аби депутати обиралися за відкритими списками,
на складення яких мали би більший вплив виборці.
Цього вимагав ще Євромайдан.
Лікар-педіатр зі Львова
був його учасником і вже три роки
займається в Києві громадською діяльностю, аби змінити країну.
По силам того Майдану було змінити не обличчя,
а змінити правила.
На жаль, після другого Майдану в нас помінялися
обличчя у владі, правила не помінялися.
Організатори нинішньої всеукраїнської акції протесту
зійшлися на трьох ключових вимогах до президента й парламенту.
Окрім зміни виборчого законодавства,
це термінове скасування депутатської
недоторканості і створення антикорупційного суду.
До цих вимог приєдналися майже півтора десятки
громадських організацій і
політичних партій з різних регіонів України.
У тому числі екс-президент Грузії Міхеіл Саакашвілі.
Він та інші не зупиняються на вимогах щодо зміни законодавства,
а прямо закликають до дострокових виборів президента і парламенту.
Цього ще мало!
Далі підемо!
Їх треба міняти просто.
Якщо ми зараз знову змінимо владу, то добре нам буде чи погано?
Я не знаю. Я до кінця не впевнений.
Мені якби скасували бідність народу.
Щоб  реформи зробили пенсійну реформу.
Молодь повинна бути тут і завдяки молоді
можна змінити країну
Утім, у мережі вирують і закиди, що, мовляв,
чимало людей приєднались до акції за гроші.
Водночас правоохоронці з МВС
як ніколи щільно перекрили підходи до адміністрації президента
та урядового кварталу.
Начебто через побоювання радикалізації мирного зібрання.
З СБУ навіть лунали заяви про можливу підготовку
демонстрантами силового сценарію.
Олександр аж ніяк не хоче пережити знову трагічні події,
як в 2014-му на Євромайдані.
Тому виступає за мирний протест, за мирний діалог з владою.
Поки він більш-менш задоволений.
Все-таки влада реагує на ці акції.
Президент вийшов з публічної обіцянкою,
що він підтримує відкриті списки регіональні
Просто треба зараз їх дотиснути.
На переконання Олександра, виконати вимоги
громадськості президент і парламент можуть, не чекаючи
наступного року або наступних виборів -
відповідні законопроекти в Верховній Раді вже є.
Якщо ж влада знов почне тягти з виконанням обіцянок,
протестувальники не виключають оголошення безстрокової акції.